Having tattoos lowers your chances of finding a job...
...and also makes people think you're a drunk.
Those two things, probably related.
Anthony here for DNews.
In a study run by the University of St Andrews in Scotland...
...showed that employers across just about all industries have a negative view of tattoos.
They used words like "dirty", "repugnant" and "abhorrent"...
...when describing how they thought their clients or customers...
...would perceive tattooed people as employees.
Well, 30% of them think that somebody with a tattoo is more likely to do something deviant.
A quarter of them think the tattooed population is less intelligent and less healthy overall.
The health response seems to be a mix of the perceived lifestyle of somebody with body art...
...and misconceptions about the actual cleanliness of the tattooing process.